just last week the taking down of Barry
is here would have been Unthinkable the
Guangzhou District of haiju the site of
a mass outbreak and lockdown blocks now
removed those testing negative release
in Beijing 2 signals of a move away from
math testing and some asymptomatic cases
are now being allowed to quarantine at
home the start may be of a seismic shift
policy change prompted by people
it's unlikely just the protests that
have bought this about it's also their
traction online an army of sensors will
have been fighting to remove videos like
this but Chinese people have seen them
and shared them tensorship machine is
like a a Warfare never end this is Eric
he now lives in America but he formally
worked as a sensor in China insights
like his are extremely rare actually is
it possible that the sensors are just
overwhelmed by how much stuff is out
there
yeah
um
through the might of the census machine
people are finding ways to outsmart the
algorithm posting videos of videos and
distortions like this to clips of key
sights
even the word Shanghai has been largely
removed but that doesn't fix the
underlying grievance
the authorities May well realize that
purely censoring what happened here may
not be enough this time the strength of
feeling is just too widespread this is a
regime that values stability above all
else there's a sense perhaps that a
strong commitment to zero covert is no
longer the best way to maintain it a
mass outbreak of covert could still
cause chaos here Community immunity is
low and the hospital system still
under-resourced any change is highly
unlikely to be swift or sweeping but it
may just may be the start Helena Smith
Sky News in Shanghai